-Il a rejoint Emmanuel Macron
en 2017,
mais mon invité
n'est pas franchement issu
de la start-up nation.
Elu de montagne,
il manie l'humour et l'autodérision
comme peu d'hommes politiques
osent le faire.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Joël Giraud.
-Bonjour.
-Vous siégez à l'Assemblée
depuis 2002, d'abord
apparenté au groupe socialiste,
puis au sein des radicaux de gauche,
aujourd'hui au sein
du groupe Renaissance,
et vous vous définissez
comme "un T-Rex du palais Bourbon",
qui a développé
sa propre technique
pour évacuer la pression
dans les moments tendus.
On va revoir un extrait
d'un reportage
de ma collègue Hélène Bonduelle,
qui vous avait suivi fin 2019
dans le marathon budgétaire,
alors que vous étiez
rapporteur général du budget.
-Quand on jongle
avec des dizaines
de milliards d'euros,
il faut se ménager des pauses.
Il chante en allemand.
Le remède au stress
pour Joël Giraud,
c'est le hard rock.
-Ah ben là,
on me dirait que ce soir,
j'ai un billet aller voir,
je sais pas...
AC/DC, tiens.
Ils sont toujours bons.
*"Engel", Rammstein
*...
-Vous avez fait ça
juste pour les caméras
ou vous rédigez vraiment
vos amendements
en écoutant du Rammstein ?
-J'écoute du Rammstein.
J'en écoute partout tout le temps
parce que j'adore ça,
et d'ailleurs,
on m'a encore offert
à mon dernier anniversaire,
ça date du mois d'octobre,
du 14 octobre,
pour être précis,
un concert de Rammstein à Lyon,
au printemps prochain.
Donc vous voyez,
je suis fidèle à la musique metal
et au metal allemand en particulier,
que je trouve particulièrement bon.
-Qu'est-ce que vous y trouvez,
dans le metal ?
Qu'est-ce que ça vous apporte ?
-Moi, ça me...
-Là, on vous voit à un concert.
-Oui, un concert de Rammstein
à Lyon, je reconnais
le stade de Lyon.
Ca m'apporte...
Comment vous dire ?
C'est l'inverse de ce que je suis
dans la vie,
je suis un mec non violent typique,
et en même temps,
je trouve que c'est une mélodie
avec une musique qui est
assez forte et engageante...
-C'est une sorte d'exutoire ?
C'est un défouloir ?
-Plus qu'un exutoire,
ça m'apporte un bien-être.
C'est... Voilà. D'ailleurs,
quand on est pas trop coincé
sur des musiques
de ce type-là,
sachez que Rammstein,
non pas dans la version
du clip qu'on a vu tout à l'heure,
parce que je pense que la dame
assez dénudée avec un serpent,
ça passerait pas,
mais sans ça,
c'est de la musique qui passe
dans tous les temples protestants
allemands
et qui est reprise
par les chorales protestantes.
Donc finalement,
vous voyez que c'est...
-Fidèle à vos racines aussi.
-Oui, mais c'est aussi fidèle
au fait qu'il faut pas
avoir d'a priori
sur les choses,
les gens et la musique.
-Ce qui vous différencie
de la plupart des députés,
c'est votre goût prononcé
pour l'humour.
On va voir une vidéo
postée sur Twitter
en 2018, vous étiez encore
rapporteur général du budget.
*Musique épique
La musique qu'on entend,
c'est la musique
du film "Men In Black".
On vous voit
avec toute votre équipe
débarquer au ministère des Finances.
Ca fait un peu descente de police.
-Oui, mais c'en était une,
puisque le rapporteur général
du budget
peut avoir un contrôle sur pièces
et sur place.
-Vous étiez allé chercher
des informations fiscales.
-J'avais besoin d'informations.
La direction
de la législation fiscale
ne me les donnait pas.
J'avais prévenu
que si je ne les avais pas,
je faisais une descente,
et j'ai fait la descente.
J'ai prévenu les cabinets la veille,
mais au petit matin,
ça a été la surprise à Bercy
quand j'ai fait savoir
que si on ne me recevait pas,
c'était du pénal.
-Vous avez mis en scène
cette démarche
de façon humoristique.
C'est pas risqué ?
Cette vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux
n'a pas plu à tout le monde.
-Elle a déplu à certaines personnes
dans l'administration de Bercy,
mais également
dans l'administration
de l'Assemblée.
Au bout d'un moment,
on l'a enlevée
parce que ça faisait polémique,
mais bon, moi, je trouvais
que c'était une bonne chose,
et c'était une bonne chose
qu'un rapporteur général
puisse prouver
qu'il est allé faire son job,
c'est-à-dire contrôler
le gouvernement
et les comptes publics.
C'est notre job, quand on est
rapporteur général du budget.
-On peut utiliser l'humour de plein
de façons différentes en politique.
Vous l'utilisez
dans quel but, vous ?
Ca vous sert à quoi en politique ?
-D'abord, je suis fait comme ça.
-Oui, c'est naturel.
-C'est naturel,
et puis de temps en temps,
quand on est un peu roublard,
j'avoue que je le suis
de temps en temps,
la petite blague
à 2 balles
fait passer quelquefois
des choses qui, sans ça,
ne passeraient pas.
-Pour faire passer un amendement ?
-Ca fait passer un amendement.
Voilà, je...
Je l'ai souvent utilisé
avec des ministres
avec lesquels ça marchait bien.
Quand Gérald Darmanin
était au Budget
en particulier,
on faisait un duo
qui était assez bon,
je dois dire, sur ce plan-là.
L'humour faisait que, finalement,
l'ambiance dans l'Assemblée
n'était pas tout à fait celle
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
pour les débats budgétaires.
-Est-ce que l'humour peut être
un moyen de jauger vos adversaires ?
-C'est une manière
d'en déstabiliser certains.
Quand les gens n'ont pas d'humour,
c'est trop sympa de les déstabiliser
en ayant de l'humour.
Donc c'est une manière aussi
de déstabiliser l'adversaire
d'une manière quand même
sympathique.
-Il y a le metal,
le goût pour les blagues
et aussi votre tenue.
Dans votre bureau,
il y a 1 chance sur 2
de vous trouver en short,
en tongs et en chemisette.
Vous confirmez ?
-Je vous confirme
que j'ai une chemisette
et pas une chemise
à manches longues.
-Ca peut donner l'image
de quelqu'un de pas sérieux,
à qui on peut pas faire confiance,
mais c'est pas l'avis
d'Edouard Philippe.
On va revoir ce qu'il disait de vous
dans l'hémicycle.
-Vous avez été capable
de démontrer,
pendant ces deux années et demie,
que la très grande connaissance
de la matière financière
et budgétaire
pouvait passer par un caractère
truculent, joyeux,
parfois farceur,
mais toujours rigoureux.
De cela,
monsieur le rapporteur général,
je veux vous remercier
au nom du gouvernement.
-Vous passiez alors la main
de ce poste
de rapporteur général du budget.
On vous sent presque ému.
-Oui, je le suis,
d'abord parce qu'Edouard Philippe
n'est pas quelqu'un
qui fait des compliments facilement
à tout le monde.
-D'ailleurs,
la question était posée
à Gérald Darmanin,
et c'est lui qui y a répondu
pour vous rendre hommage.
-C'est ça.
J'ai apprécié le personnage,
son côté extrêmement sérieux
qui cache quand même, j'allais dire,
presque de la tendresse.
Et là, c'est vrai
que c'était moi
qui étais déstabilisé
parce que je ne m'attendais pas
à un tel éloge...
-Qui montre
qu'on peut faire
de la politique
sérieusement
sans se prendre au sérieux.
-C'est la bonne solution.
Sans ça, vous vous rendez compte,
depuis le temps
que je fais de la politique,
je me serais ennuyé.
-Vous avez un parcours assez riche.
On va revenir sur vos débuts.
Vous étiez parti
pour faire carrière dans la haute
fonction publique, et en 1989,
vous vous êtes présenté
pour devenir maire
de L'Argentière-la-Bessée,
dans les Hautes-Alpes.
Vous dites que c'est au nom
de votre père
que vous l'avez fait.
-Complètement. Mon père
était maire de cette commune,
et cette commune a subi
un désastre absolu :
la fermeture
d'une usine Péchiney.
Mon père en est mort.
Il a eu un premier AVC
en 85, un second en 86,
parce qu'il voyait
tout ce pour quoi il avait vécu
disparaître.
Donc je me suis présenté
au nom de mon père
parce que je pensais
qu'il fallait
prendre le relais derrière lui
pour reconstruire un avenir
à la commune
qu'il n'avait pas eu le temps
de mettre en oeuvre
et ce qui l'avait largement fait
disparaître. Ces images...
-La destruction de l'usine Péchiney.
-J'ai chialé,
pas quand j'ai vu l'usine tomber,
là, c'était les ouvriers,
c'était leur lieu de travail,
mais pour la cheminée,
c'était le symbole.
Mais tous les gens qui ont vécu
dans des endroits industriels,
dans les bassins miniers
ou sidérurgiques
du nord et de l'est,
ont le même sentiment.
C'est un sentiment de tragédie.
Vous avez l'impression
que tout s'arrête.
-Il y a chez vous une vraie fierté
à venir d'un territoire rural
C'est votre principal moteur
en politique,
défendre la ruralité face aux normes
imposées par la capitale.
Ca remonte à loin.
Je crois que
vous l'avez même manifesté
le premier jour
de votre arrivée
à l'ENA.
-Oui, parce que nous avons été reçus
de manière séparée.
Il y avait les élèves
des concours
interne et externe,
les élèves issus
de l'Ecole normale supérieure
des postes et télécommunications,
ceux de la ville de Paris,
et on ne recevait pas les gens
en même temps. Moi, j'étais
à la fois du concours interne
et de la filière postes et télécoms,
donc j'étais plus rural
que les autres.
Le directeur des études
nous a dit
qu'il conviendrait
de ne point trop exhiber
notre ruralité.
J'ai trouvé ça lunaire.
Donc je me suis levé,
je me suis gratté les fesses
et j'ai pris la porte.
Je peux pas supporter
cette espèce de regard parisien
absolument insupportable,
qui n'existe
dans aucun autre pays d'Europe.
Il y a que la France
où on a une telle coupure
entre la capitale
et le reste du monde,
c'est-à-dire la province.
-En 2020, vous êtes passé
du côté parisien.
On vous a nommé au gouvernement
au poste
de secrétaire d'Etat
à la Ruralité.
Vous vous êtes retrouvé aux manettes
pour résoudre
tous les problèmes
pour lesquels vous vous étiez engagé
en politique, non ?
-C'était le poste dont je rêvais...
-Et le bilan ?
-...d'autant que la Ruralité
incluait la montagne.
Donc pour moi,
c'était important.
Le bilan, écoutez, il y avait
181 mesures de l'agenda rural
qui avaient été décidées
du temps d'Edouard Philippe,
et Jean Castex
et Emmanuel Macron
m'ont demandé
de les mettre en oeuvre,
et je les ai toutes
mises en oeuvre, une par une,
et j'en ai même ajouté deux,
parce qu'on ne parlait
ni d'égalité hommes-femmes
ni d'égalité des droits LGBT
en milieu rural.
Donc ça fait 183.
Et puis je crois
que j'ai fait le job.
D'ailleurs, les territoires
le reconnaissent plutôt.
-Vous avez parlé
de ce que vous avez ajouté
sur les droits des LGBT
en milieu rural.
C'est un dispositif
pour aider les jeunes gays
qui se retrouvent
mis à la porte de chez eux
par leurs parents
quand ils n'acceptent pas
leur homosexualité.
-C'est complètement ça.
-Une question personnelle.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous avez vécu
dans votre histoire familiale ?
-Non, j'ai été rejeté par personne.
-Parce que vous avez eu
une phrase...
-Ca plaisait pas énormément
à mon père.
-"Il n'a jamais accepté
"de voir un mec dans mon pieu."
-Voilà. Bon, ça, c'est vrai...
Mais je connais peu de pères
qui acceptent ce genre de chose.
Voilà, ça s'est arrêté là,
mais dans la société...
Après, j'ai fait
une carrière politique.
Les secrets de polichinelle...
C'est même pas la peine
de l'exprimer ou d'en rajouter.
Je ne suis un militant de rien,
et ça ne doit pas être
un sujet à mettre sur la table
si ce n'est pour éviter
les discriminations,
ce que j'ai fait
en tant que ministre.
-Aujourd'hui,
vous l'assumez.
On vous voit
tous les ans
à la marche des fiertés rurales
dans la Vienne, ici chevauchant
une licorne arc-en-ciel.
-Les autres députés
avaient mis l'écharpe
bleu-blanc-rouge.
J'ai été un peu moins sobre.
-Vous aviez pas le même look, non.
-Non, mais la licorne a survécu,
ce qui est important.
-Bon, on va conclure
par notre quiz, à présent.
Vous allez pouvoir
compléter les phrases
que je vais vous proposer.
Prêt ?
-Oh, prêt.
-Le jour où je ne blaguerai plus...
-Je serai mort.
-Ah oui, clairement.
C'est tellement dans votre ADN...
-Ah oui, je n'y arriverai pas.
Je dois blaguer tout le temps,
je n'y arrive pas autrement.
-Moi, président
de l'Assemblée...
-Eh bien,
moi, président
de l'Assemblée nationale,
je rassemblerais vraiment
les forces vives
de l'ensemble
des mouvements politiques
pour essayer de trouver
à l'allemande
un certain nombre de consensus.
Je crois que ça peut être fait.
-Un peu de Rammstein
dans l'hémicycle...
-Mmh !
Ca serait un grand bonheur,
et ça, je crois,
décrisperait pas mal l'ambiance.
-Merci beaucoup,
Joël Giraud, d'être venu
dans "La politique et moi".
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...